hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
patterns of intra host and intra host
variation in
sars kovi 2. this webinar is part of the
ongoing coronavirus webinar series
i'm susie valdez elaborate and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you'd like during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply click on the ask a question block
located on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credit without further ado i now present
to today's
speaker dr todd triangan
assistant professor computer science at
rice university and the co-lead kobit 19
international research team for a
complete biography of our speaker
you can go to the biography tab at the
top of your screen
doctor triangus you may now begin your
presentation
welcome sir
great thank you thanks so much um and
thanks for this opportunity
to present today so i'll just get right
into it and that was a great
introduction thank you susie thanks
thanks to everyone
at lab roots for for making this happen
um so today as as
was mentioned i will be discussing
patterns of
within person interhost another way of
saying that variation
and sars kovi ii and as was mentioned i
am
i'm an assistant professor in the
computer science department at rice
university in houston texas
so just get right into it
so just to get started i'm here's a
high-level outline i wanted to
share with you before we get into it and
and basically this is divided
into six parts and and i'll start off
with the introduction background and on
kind of motivation and in in concepts
that i'll discuss
i'll then get into a high-level summary
of what i mean by inter-host variant
landscape i will
present that i will do some comparative
analyses of some of these terms that
i'll discuss
throughout the presentation um and then
talk about some of the potential impact
of
of of what these uh snps or snips and is
nvs
are uh on mucker testing and utility of
these uh
for potentially tracking transmission of
kv19
and then i'll offer some concluding
remarks so
let's just go ahead and get started um
so just just
as as was mentioned i wanted to you know
re-emphasize the learning objectives of
this talk is it
you know kind of three main things i
wanted to highlight you know
by the end uh those listening to this
presentation should be able to
think about differentiating consensus
level versus within host variation
stars kobe 2 what that means uh how we
can go about doing that
as a learning objective number two uh i
would i would
like everyone to think about and learn
uh what what's the potential impact
of these single nucleotide variations on
e19 diagnostics and as a as a third
and uh final learning objective it's
kind of to understand the utility of
this these minor variants or intra host
uh
single nucleotide variants on tracking
sars kobe 2 transmission
so those are the three primary
objectives
and then so we'll get right into it um
so just part one background
uh so historical perspective i thought
this was a very interesting
and useful way to start it off is back
in 2003
december there was a paper published in
nature reviews microbiology by the
co-authors listed on the screen
titled sars beginning to understand a
new virus
and so here we sit you know 17 and
you know years years later more or less
and and i i feel like you could replace
that
with sars kobe 2 uh beginning to
understand a new virus
and so well we'll i'll start to get into
what i mean by that but i thought this
was an appropriate way to begin this
this is
um related and and and and kind of
other related to previous efforts and
and then
i'm going to take a deep dive into soros
kobe 2 so just wanted to highlight this
um so background i'm not going to get
into all of the biology
behind sars kobe 2 and incumbent but i
will
highlight a few things very brief on
march 11
2020 the who determined that an outbreak
of a novel coronavirus
now that we know is called sarsko v2 it
began in
china late december 2019 and it had
reached pandemic status
um initial analyses of these
few initial genomes that became
available uh indicated
a few things but then it was mutational
rate was similar to other coronaviruses
so
as as data was arriving we were thinking
that this looked similar to other
coronaviruses but it was still kind of
as you as you get data we were
interpreting it
but one important point is is important
in order to properly assess the
diversity of of any
rna virus and specifically star scoby 2
it's really important and necessary to
consider the intra-host variation as
well and that's kind of one of the main
points of this whole
uh talk that i'm giving today so i just
wanted to highlight that and that's
you uh the in in segwaying and from that
we're we're high level and like and
there's not gonna be tons of biology
here but we'll
one slide will dedicate to this this is
um looks like um uh this is a figure
from uh
stadler at all um and
and and this is describing high level
what the
what the source covey ii or it's
actually the cyroscopy one genome looks
like but it's uh
high level this is a coronavirus and and
so
what what does it mean like what what
what are important factoids you can take
away from this figure well
number one this is around a thirty
thousand base pair or thirty thousand
character for thinking this as a string
thirty thousand character
uh genome um it's it's small
so but complex it's another thing we can
take away from this figure from this
previous publication
so so we see a complement of
non-structural structural and accessory
proteins across the genome
but really it's you know it's a 30 000
character string
that we really want to dive in and
deeply understand what's going on
at the genome level at the consensus
level and
also at the minor varia or intra host
snv level okay and then and then just to
segue a little bit
one initial question alluding to my
first slide how does
sars compare to tsar's kobe 2. so
next discuss that so so for those that
are not
familiar with these concepts i will keep
it pretty high level um
but when we look at sequence similarity
the similarity between if we were to
take
that string which represents sars or
star score b1 and compare it
to soros kobe 2 and count all of the
differences
and similarities so essentially 100
percent similarity means every single
base pair in the 30 000 base pair genome
when we compare it from star score v1 to
surface kobe 2
uh is is the same and then and then zero
percent would be
they're all different so these number
putting these numbers into perspective
certain non-structural proteins between
cyroscopy one and stars cov2 are
identical
this would be nsp7 and nsp13
so nsp7 is involved in the rna
polymerase complex
and nsp13 is a helicase and those are
100 identical
across their length so so those two it's
if we're comparing stars kobe 2 with
stars k1 they're identical
and then we get into some more diverse
regions so if we look at other regions
this is now a non-structural protein in
an orb
uh open reading frame so we have sars
code one and two again and
this time it's 86 percent similarity and
85 percent similarity so again if this
is if this
the length of these which which it isn't
is 100 uh
100 characters that means these two
differ by about 14 positions across that
100 character string so
uh and and these two are this one's
involved in nsp3s involved in viral
replication
and then orf9b is uh thought to be
involved in type one interfering
antagonist okay so so we have identical
we have
clearly not identical and about you know
14 or 15 different
and then we have regions that are really
really different
and i say the unknown where you know
there's this orph called
or eight and stars coming to that has
very little sequence similarity
uh two stars kobe one not really the
same thing so
just to give high-level landscape when
you're comparing these two genomes
you have some identical regions you have
some uh diverse
or more different regions then you have
very very different regions
okay so next
um what i already mentioned these two
terms you know what what what are we
talking about when i
when i say s p or snip and isnv
or intra host single loop type variant
what do i mean by that well i have an
example here
for you so essentially uh when we uh go
to
sequence uh stars cov2 from kavadin and
positive patients we're gonna
take a nasal swab or other sample
and we'll uh swab that and then we'll uh
put it on a do some library prep and lab
prep and then we'll put on a sequence
sequencer but as you see in this this uh
black box here with the green circles
when we do that we're actually what
we're actually doing is sequencing a
population of genomes it's a population
of
individual virions or cells
corresponding to kobe 2
population inside of that um that nasal
specimen nasal swab or whatever okay so
we have all of these different colors
which represent different actual
individual virions corresponding stars
could be two
okay so but the sequencer will give us
all of these black boxes that we call
reads so these are dna
these are sequencing reads and then so
we see c
a t c g a t that's one such
uh sequencing uh read that will come out
and then
uh genome assembly algorithms we'll
stitch all those together and we'll
reconstruct the consensus sequence that
we list at the top there
that's that's essentially putting the
puzzle together you can think of the dna
sequencing the sequencing reads as
the puzzle pieces and then the consensus
sequence at the top is
kind of kind of the puzzle put together
so when i refer to
snips or singling type polymorphisms i'm
referring
to changes that occur at this consensus
level if we stack all of these reads up
and we make a consensus call this would
be the
position inside of that genome or
consensus okay
and then when i talk about intra-host
signaling data variants
isnvs or minor variants i'm referring to
individual changes that we could find
inside
reads and and maybe don't reach the
consensus level but they're present so i
have an example highlighted there
there's two cs on the right
that are contained in two breeds and so
that would be considered an isnv
so just consensus level is when we take
we glomerate all the information
we can think of it simply as if 50
or more of the individual reads at a
position support a given
base pair that will be the consensus and
anything below that will be an isnv
okay so that's an important i'm going to
refer to these terms repeatedly moving
forward
and then furthermore once we once we now
have these consensus genomes
across patients so so intra-host we have
the reeds and then once we have this
consensus genome we can now use that
consensus
to compare sars kovi to similar uh you
know from from covey
positive patients across the length of
their genome and these are called
again single nucleotide polymorphisms or
snips so we see
some highlighted regions of what you
know what snips are
and on the left is a mock phylogenetic
tree which relates
uh these genomes based on their
evolutionary history
so so again this is primarily the drive
home
the difference between an uh a snip and
an isnv
okay with that said we're going to talk
a little bit about data now so so now we
have
is nvs and snips covered and a little
bit of the biology
they do any of the analyses i'll present
we need access to data and fortunately
this has been a global effort of many
contributors depositing their sequence
uh data
inside of ncbi genbank so to date we
have
uh around 5000 sequences um in inside of
our publicly accessible database at ncbi
and and then we have um over six
thousand
uh sra sequences which would be the the
read
the read data sets okay so we can if we
were to click on this link which i won't
do you can
go there and you can anyone could go
there and access and download all this
data
okay so that's kind of step one uh
another great resource and primary
resource is uh
just aid gis aid
and this here we're gonna actually have
access to
over thirty two thousand complete uh
sarso v2 genomes um these are assembled
data as i described in the previous
slide
a login is required you have to go there
you have to create an account but once
you do create an account
you can download these data and you can
look at them and compare
there are there there are some
restrictions but essentially the
datasets i'm describing
are from ncbi or this data set
this is where we're going to enter
genome data and then other sources uh
along with uh collaborators on a uh in
the
company 19 international research team
there's there's a compiled open science
foundation repository
where you can access data that that i
will discuss today
there is a cup id 19 data lake
hosted by c3 ai with lots of great
information
and then of course probably one of the
more most well-known resources
is the amazing resource uh next strain
uh
where if you click on the link they've
been just doing an amazing job at
keeping up to date tracking of all this
information pulling the
genomic information and showing all this
so there's a lot of
data out there uh for for conducting the
analysis that i'll describe
okay and then finally um
i will just show an image of a
phylogenetic tree of all of the
say genome assemblies um contained in
that database i said there were now
30 32 000 this phylogenetic tree is
based off of 7 000 of those genomes
and i'll walk you through this figure
this figure is a little bit complex but
we'll
walk through it um so at the inner the
inner level there's a phylogenetic tree
that's
uh that was that was created based off
of the
the genome alignments but essentially we
can think of this as
uh we're looking at uh the sars two
genomes
and where uh any any genomes uh
near each other are evolutionary
related and and and so i don't have time
to unfortunately get into this
a full description but uh the next the
next layer is going to be
uh the cotton the continent from which
these genomes originated
so we have this phylogenetic tree which
is looking at the
uh the snips and ice uh primarily the
snips
and and how genomes are different or
differ
and and how similar they are and we we
build this tree and then and then we're
looking coloring on the next
so we see purple and black and red
these are all indicating continent of
origin so we can label this with with
these colors and then and then on the
outer layers we actually see
what what what's been called clade
defining snips and these are
the signal nuclei polymorphisms i've
previously described
that essentially are specific to
certain sets of genomes inside of these
clades inside of the phylogenetic tree
okay so just as a little bit of a teaser
kind of global information seven
thousand genomes
how they all relate by continent and by
these snips that i
referenced previously okay so
then now the analysis that i'll do uh
moving forward um
well we'll kind of primarily uh rely on
this uh
but that for the isbn snip analysis on
sars kobe 1 samples sars kobe 2 samples
we'll compare these to mers another
coronavirus
um and and and and we'll compare these
because we really want to look at
how source cov2 is different from these
other
coronaviruses and specifically look at
this intra-host diversity of cytoskob2
so we're getting into part two now part
two we're going to cover high-level
summary of intra-hospital landscape
as a reminder i just recently presented
this but as a reminder
when i say intra-host remember within a
given host we're going to have
all of these green circles which each
contain
a copy of a genome for a specific source
code vq
and we're going to now really look at
the differences at the at the read level
not at the consensus level but at the
read level
and what's going on within a individual
a single 19 patient
okay and so what what what do we mean
what what what's what
we how do we analyze that gap
essentially we take
take an existing genome assembly for
source cov2
maybe the first ones from uh
and for the reference genome which
i ref one of my initial slides
and we reads and see how they
uh compare to that wuhan reference so
we're going to use algorithms
bioinformatic algorithms to actually
align them to that reference and then
we're going to look at them and we're
going to see all the differences inside
of those reads compared to that
reference
okay so if we dig in a little bit deeper
this is this is what we call a you know
aligned region and
this this is a sequence alignment of
of the pile of all those reads
to that reference and we see mostly that
everything looks
differences in these reads with
from a individual person but understand
what are all these differences caused by
and what's going on within percent
so highlighting a lit we can now see
very
faintly some
some dip d in this three reed support
that are different from that
reference and we see um some other some
other positions as well
and and again importantly to clarify you
know we can map this to a reference or
we can actually assemble out the genome
for a given person
and then map all the reads back to that
to find these
um okay and then and then one of the
major challenges here one of the major
challenges is
how do we know this low lower frequency
this intra-host smv is not a
sequencing error because the dna
sequencing technologies can also
generate
uh you know errors when they when you
get one of those reads out so how do we
know that this is not just an
error or if it's actually true or
variation within a sample
unfortunately we have some tools
available to us
that can help tease out error
from actual uh is nvs and one of those
tools is
uh what we use is loaffreak but
unfortunately i don't have time to get
into the algorithm but
i think thankfully we have tools like
that out there that can help us with
this okay
so so once we uh compare all those reads
or map all those
uh to that within that single patient
genome we're going to look at what are
all the differences and there's
certain differences that we can observe
uh here and this is what this this first
plot is and it's what i'm calling
mutational landscape of
s fees or snips and ice and v's okay so
if we look at how
if you remember all the previous slides
i presented if we look at exactly all
the individual differences we see
within within a person but also
at the snip level across genomes or in
interhost
uh we see um a to t changes a to c
changes a to g
c d c to g g to t et cetera okay on the
left
and so this is one of the first
observations i wanted to share with
everyone
was if you look at all of the colors we
have snip levels as
i've described from houston in new york
city we have
intra-host variants also from houston
and new york city
and then we have those just a genomes
which we've calculated snips so
just highlighting a couple of these we
see something like an a to g
change pretty much consistent across all
those different types of
of variants whether it's intra-host or
inter-host or snip level
another interesting observation however
is the c to t changes
we see in some of the samples such as
the houston isnv and the giseted snips
to be around
30 to 40 percent if we look at the
houston and new york city snips we see
um
higher much higher and then if we look
at the new york city from the
from the chris mason lab that was
provided the sequence data that we see
that actually the
interhost smvs for cd changes is
actually below 20
and this is what i mean by landscape we
want to dig in and see what are all the
changes within person and the crosstalk
um for this virus and on the right we
see kind of a similar
story uh in the sense that we're looking
at these
specific changes but now we're comparing
it from sars kobe to
sars to mers and we see some interesting
patterns again
uh sars certainly sticks out and certain
changes looks a lot different
mers and sarsko v2 look pretty similar
for some of these changes
but once again we see some interesting
patterns in c to t changes where we see
stars kobe 2 and mers maybe closer to
one another than what sars is so this is
what i mean by digging into the
landscape and and we start to see
patterns
um so uh interestingly there was a
recent paper published in science
advances by d
giorgio at all and they found similar
patterns in their data
looking at similar things see the t
changes but they
they also found slightly different
patterns where they saw a lot of
to see changes maybe more than what we
saw
in a different figure and when when
they're looking at the data
a different way where you're looking at
snip level changes
uh the c to t changes do become dominant
so
um it's it's very interesting um
and something i wanted to point out
forever there are recent studies which
highlight some of these changes but
this is kind of exploratory analysis
based on all the channel
the the data sets that i described out
there so
the next part i would like to do is a
comparative analyses of
snips and ice and v's and we want to
look at them and say our you know what
differences or
can we observe between them or or are
they just the same patterns
so um what we have on the screen now is
an upset plot
capturing overlaps or intersections
between
snips and ice and v's in the sarskv2
data
and what i mean by overlaps are
intersections it means these
intra host snbs are occurring at the
same positions where snips occur
and genomes so if we look at the genome
again we said it was 30 000 base pairs
long
we take position 1000 we find in some
genomes that there's a snip there
and then some some in intra host data if
you're looking at the reads we find
we'll we map them or align them back to
that uh
that you know host specific genome
assembly
we find in that position thousand
there's an isnv there
okay so that's what we're looking at and
we'll get into why we think that's
interesting or why i think that's
interesting
but as we can see in this upset plot
there's a lot of
just aidsnips that only exist as snips
on the far left there are a lot of those
same for the new york city ice and bees
but what i find really interesting is
when we start looking at
intersections in this in the upset plot
where we see intersection from the new
york city is nvs and then just say snips
so these are
inter-host smvs that occur in the new
york city samples and and also are found
as snips into just a
genome data that are contributed by the
the broader community that's
very generously so and we anyone once
you apply for account you can access
them
another really interesting observation
is when you look at um
you know sets of three where you can
find for example uh
in new york city snip is nv and just a
snip
there's 13 of those where they occur so
you so this is what i mean
i'm not going to go through all the
numbers here on this figure but overall
when you start looking at these
intra-host signaling stead variants
these these snips in the genomes you
start seeing some really interesting
patterns in terms of within
person variation and also across the
genomic data across multiple individuals
so um another way of looking at this
is you take all of the uh snips again
and you look across the genome remember
i said it was a thirty thousand base
pair genome
and left to right you're essentially
seeing positions
if there's a bar there a tall blue bar
it's essentially
going to indicate positions that are
variable with respect to snips
so this gives you some sense of across
the genome how variable it is
i would suspect that the snips again
when we're doing going back to that
phylogenetic tree i showed
7000 genomes we're seeing all these
snips and you see some really
interesting um positions that are highly
variable
and then the top row is again getting
back into the non-structural proteins
and
structural proteins and of specific
dosars kobe 2. so you can
align these variable variable positions
for example in nsp
12 we see a position around 15 000 base
pairs that's highly variable followed by
a couple more
okay so we're looking at this global
landscape of snips across the genome and
we're also doing a deep dive in
within the within the host and looking
at what's going on quote unquote behind
the scenes
okay so now if if we want to look at
simply something that that i'll kind of
briefly cover is we want to look at are
these
changes um synonymous or non-synonymous
okay we want to know if
these snips or intra-host single-instead
variants results in a synonymous change
or non-synonymous change
and what i mean by that is um for the
specif
for there's redundancy uh in the genetic
code
so different codons so different
triplets of eight you know
of agc cnts can can
go different amino acids sometimes you
can change one of those
and still have the same amino acid
sometimes when you change it it results
in a different one which will
uh likely that'll induce a
non-synonymous change which could have
an effect on the protein protein
structure
okay so this is all this plot is showing
we won't get into the
specific details here but essentially we
wanted to compare
what did we see with respect to new york
city
sars and mers okay so it's
it's it's an interesting pattern where
we see that
uh inside of the sars samples we saw
a very low mean sn value and mean uh
pi a sample which is giving us is giving
us some sense of the diversity and
complexity
of the inter-host single nuclear
variance within a person
um and we see some differences there so
that's that's
all this is really is the main takeaway
from here we see some differences across
these different coronaviruses in terms
of complexity and diversity
and then if we get into the
non-synonymous and synonymous mutation
ratios so actually now dividing this and
getting to a ratio
we see that again there are differences
okay and and some interesting things
here
are again the differences between sars
and
the new york city inter-host signified
variants and then the merge samples so
that dotted line at one um anything
above that
where uh this is uh out of
positive uh selection and then if you're
at one you're neutral and then below it
it's thought of as
kind of purifying or negative selection
so so essentially
are these changes yeah you know what's
the result of these changes so most of
these changes what does this mean
if you're below that line most of these
changes
most of them are going gonna be uh
synonymous okay
and then and then for the ratio and if
you're above the line
it's you're gonna have more uh hints of
more uh
non-synonymous changes with respect to
synonymous changes if that makes sense
okay so if you write the line there's an
equal ratio there if you're below it
there's
more synonymous changes than
non-synonymous and if you're above that
line there's more
so we see some really interesting
patterns okay and then on the right plot
we're comparing
the the intra-host uh i the singularity
variants with this with the
snip data and we see some also some
slight differences
there as well so we're thinking about
this in the in the context of
non-cinemas versus synonymous
uh mutation ratios so this is another
really interesting
data point for us thinking about the the
the landscape okay
and then we're getting into part four uh
we're going to think about
the potential impact of snips and ice
and visa molecular testing
right so we've seen some patterns now
we've seen some patterns we've looked at
kind of complexing a little bit of the
diversity of these ice vs
uh but what's up what are there hints of
a potential impact on blocker testing
okay so so high level just backing up a
second
uh available methods from for molecular
testing include
direct detection approaches such as real
real-time reverse transcription
pcr probes so qrt pcr
uh tacman array probes other pro based
technologies even crispr
cast based technologies we can also use
sequencing based approaches
where we do direct you know metagenomic
metatranscriptomic sequencing
pcr amplicon sequencing and targeted
applicant sequencing so these are kind
of our available
tools inside of our toolkit toolbox for
for for testing for the presence of
wd19 on on the molecular side and
there's other there's other
other techniques as well but we'll focus
on these and what are pros and cons
um for direct versus sequencing so
direct detection approaches tend to be
faster
uh can be and not always but overall
tend to be faster you can get a you can
get
go from sample to answer sometimes in a
few minutes or
30 minutes or 90 minutes or a few hours
can can can be multiplexed for multiple
samples or targets
um and then and then sequencing based
approaches
uh provide the full genome you're going
to get access to the full genome instead
of targeted regions of the
sars cov2 virus and we can use that to
detect co-infections
uh typically it is slower and more
expensive and
importantly typically the sequencing
based approaches require additional
bioinformatic analyses
so those are kind of our options here um
so
the direct detection approaches have
been pretty commonly used for kavaidi
19. if anyone's seen the the
nasal swabs or nasopharyngeal suaves you
you get swabbed and then and then you
get
you'll get that's why we're going to
analyze
typically through one of these direct
detection approaches for a fast and
usually reliable result
and and but but why this is important in
the context of what we previously
discussed
is again as as it's kind of targeted
you're looking at specific regions in
that in the source cov2 genome
again 30 000 base pair genome we're
going to target a few regions and we see
if we see these regions
present we're going to call that as you
know a positive we're going to it's more
complicated than that but
given given the limitations of the time
i have for the presentation we'll just
leave it at that but we're going to
target maybe three to four regions
across the genome
with these specific 20 20 base pair to
30 base pair sequences so that we can
say if we see
these as present we're going to say okay
sorry kobe 2
uh this is a curve id 19 positive
patient and and if not it's going to be
a negative
okay so we have listed in the left uh
figure and the right figure the left
figure
are the uh interhosting olympic
diversions and on the right are the
snips
and each row is actually one primer
probe
and available direct testing approaches
based on what i just previously
described
so what we did is we took all of those
and then we overlaid
the is nvs and steps on top of them and
so
the landscape of that we previously
observed we see
that many of the primer and probes
actually do have uh presence of snips
and icing these in them
okay and we haven't done the value
validation of actually
demonstrating this is going to make it
so you know result in a false negative
test but this could reduce efficacy or
result in a
could result in a false negative for
some of these commonly used
tests so this is something good to keep
in mind for the implication of the snips
and ice and these we've previously
discussed
and to kind of solidify this point a
recent paper that just came out
at the end of may uh described exactly
this the presence of mismatches between
diagnostic pcrsas and coronavirus
stars could be two genome uh so so i
listed that paper
um it's a really nice read on kind of
going in there and understanding
the effects of the mismatches between
the genome and what i just described
okay but for the terms of time i will
have to move on
and then i'll end with the potential
utility of is vs for kvid19 transmission
analyses and i'll describe exactly next
what i mean by that
okay so why do we care about
transmission well
essentially um when we spread
uh stars kobe 2 um we don't just spread
you know you know just just this
consensus sequence it's possible
we're spreading multiple copies of you
know these these
uh this genome via the cells or the
virions
so in this figure we see we have a um
we have a donor um we have the virus you
know gets in it replicates and then and
then
let's say we cough or sneeze or however
however
we transmit it the recipient may get one
single copy or more or but
and that's that's what we'll talk about
but essentially these these
uh these individual um
kind of cells or variants that we can
look at through the read data
as i mentioned could be helpful for
saying
this recipient actually received the
virus from said donor
okay and that's that's kind of number
one number one
is kind of the first thing to think
about and then and then
number two though there's uh this
concept of transmission bottleneck is
the number of viral particles initiating
each new infection
okay so if the donor has a lot of
variance but
so so the role of bottleneck size so we
have a large
population spinal exercise
kind of has it has a different effect
when the virus viral population is small
so think about we have a diverse
population we want to understand
how many possibly of these
uh bearings would would transmit to to a
recipient
okay so moving on to the the next slide
just looking at this slightly
differently uh and similar to what we've
talked about previously
putting it all together we have some
donor with some copies
of the varian this was our original
figure we sequenced those as i said
before we identify
some of these have some
uh isnv's right we can look at the
frequencies
of those ismbs uh and then we can look
at the recipient
uh uh maybe a puget transmission pair
maybe this we know it's a family member
uh that is club id positive now that has
a few copies
we can sequence that the the the
recipient as well we can
look at the reads uh we can look at the
the
is nvs and we can compare we can say is
there
does this profile look like it's similar
or does it look dissimilar and there's
many factors which would contribute to
that
but the interest of time that's kind of
what what i wanted to bring up
so this is what we did we next did so
in that same data set that i described
we looked at a
shared inter-host single new side
variants again going back to the same
position
across pairs of individuals in this new
york city
study provided by the chris mason lab so
we looked at all of this
and we found some really interesting
pairs while the top
left figure figure a most pairs
didn't share anything but there were a
few
pairs inside of this data set of a
hundred and forty samples that we saw
shared interhost signaling tied variants
so
um on the top right we see that the
number of samples
that contain a given isnv varies there
are some that are very prolific that
that occur in many samples so maybe
they're not informative we see an isd
there's some technical reasons why these
could be artifacts etc we see them occur
a lot of genomes and then we see on the
right hand of
the figure panel b that there are some
that occur in a very
few you know fewer genomes okay maybe
less than 10.
um then the last thing we can do is
using some
modeling algorithms we can look at on
the left is this this bar
pod that's kind of a dark gray and
compared to this dark green the dark
grey is let's say it's a
fugitive recipient we don't know but
let's say for the the sake of the
presentation
and the gree is greenest potential uh
the uh
the donor or vice versa and we can look
at the common
uh is nvs across those two patients and
we look at the frequency at which they
occur
and we found some really interesting
patterns we see some positions
for some of these ice and v's are at
very similar frequencies
from putative a donor to recipient
for both c1 and c2 in this figure okay
and all i want to say with that is this
they're this hints at potential utility
of these ice and b's for tracking
transmission of sars kobe 2 across
patients and of course there are some
recent studies on this that i won't have
time to describe
all right so with that i will get into
my conclusion
um i will just say
start by saying diverse intra-host
variant landscape
uh in stars going to including isnb
snips
and and and other variants
and this varies from the just say
genomic data as i described from new
york city samples to houston samples
that were analyzed for this study um
multiple intra-hosts is nvs and snips
were found
within commonly used probe and primers
for milker pcr detection
this is something that is and but
just to highlight should be taken into
account for primary probe design
to assure effective detection and limit
false
false negatives and then multiple uh the
last point is multiple uh
ismvs were shared between hosts and some
at high allele frequency
uh this suggests the white bottleneck
and potential also gives that
is some hints at their potential utility
for tracking transmission
okay and with that i would like to
acknowledge
uh many people uh there's many people
that contributed uh
to these analyses i just was fortunate
to be able to present this to you all
um but first i'll uh i'll start with my
my my lab
my postdoc in my lab leo elworth
major role in all these analysis and and
ph.d student uh
nicolas sapoval who who led most of
these analysis
uh maria wang who contributed heavily to
transmission analyses uh
all major contributions to the work and
and hats off to them for doing all the
analyses
and then i want to say you know
also highlight uh uh
dr fritz sidlaczik's uh efforts and and
as he's
kind of the co-lead co-senior author on
the study uh leading the charge on the
structural variant analysis which i
didn't have time to cover today uh in
his postdoc medhat
mood um and then others i won't read
through all the names uh but there's
everyone on the slide deserves uh
you know acknowledgements and then
special thanks also to the mason lab
specifically christopher mason
for providing a lot of the samples uh
the data for the samples that were
presented
today and
with that i will go off on a slight
tangent
i would like to highlight the cub id 19
international research team it's my
great honor and privilege to do this and
share this with you today
i am fortunate to be a co-lead of this
international research team alongside
efficiency
this originated from a nasa glam
multi-old mix analysis working group
that affine leads i was a member of that
and we
proposed uh working together on kavadi
covey 19 research back in march
so since then uh thanks to all the
members this is
just that that have joined and
contributed
all of their nights and weekends and
their tireless efforts to it this has
grown
uh immensely and it's very excited to
share this with everyone today
please do check it out um but you have
many members with diverse expertise all
working together
open in an open science fashion um and
so
it's been very excited to be i've been
very excited and privileged to be
involved with this
we have a website it's www.cov
hyphen irt.org this is the landing page
for the website
please do check it out i can provide the
links later
and then importantly we are hosting our
second symposium
friday july 17th at 10 a.m um
central time and this is to save the day
more details to follow we're finalizing
the
speaker agenda now it's coming together
really really well and so i'm excited to
soon share that with everyone but if
you're interested please do
save that data like more details to
follow
and then just give you an idea a little
bit more about
covert we are i said international
research team i'm very excited to say
we're we're in multiple countries across
the globe
um across the us and across the globe
and we're actively creating new members
in some of the
countries where we don't have
representation but again this has been
just
just all thanks to all the members that
join and contribute
all their time and effort and work
together on this very important problem
and just to acknowledge all of the
members this is not all but this is the
latest up-to-date one that i had it's
missing a few members but
leave her 120 members and counting
potentially more at this point
several more but uh you know we have
representation
across the us across the globe many
different institutions
and and yeah just just really amazing
strong team and
again very fortunate to work with
everyone so
so with that i will i will conclude
my presentation and happy to take any
questions you might have
thank you so much dr triangine for that
informative presentation
and clearly important research we will
now
start the q a portion of this webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's take a look
at the incoming
questions that are already here from our
audience members and thank you again
audience
for these great questions doctor
what why are the uh snps
insufficient for tracking transmission
of covid19
yeah that's that's a great question and
and something that you know that could
be a presentation on itself but i had to
kind of
you know maybe go a little little faster
but um essentially
uh when we look at the genomes of
of of two stars covey ii uh
virus that were transmitted from person
a to person b um
it could be that they are identical at
this at the consensus or snip level so
we look at the we
sequence the genomes that i described we
assemble those genomes for the specific
patient a and patient b and then we
compare them as i described and we look
at across the 30 000 base pair genome
if this is a direct transmission event
it's possible that these genomes are
identical or nearly identical so the
reason they're insufficient is that
there could just be no
snips that they're essentially so we can
say okay well they're identical
and and this this could be the same for
a cluster of recent genomes that are all
identical so we could say okay well
they're all
within a pool of very similar genomes
maybe differ by zero
one or two snips but we can think of is
nvs
as extra kind of firepower or quote
unquote unquote to actually look into
and say okay well for
we have multiple genomes from multiple
patients not just a and b but now we
have
h and a b c and d and e all identical
but now we find
a pair inside of that those five that
also share inter single enzyme variants
this gives us extra confidence
additional confidence to say this likely
represents a transmission event
so it's not that they're always
insufficient but
sometimes they may be insufficient
because of
or certain transmission scenarios um
it just could be that it's part of a
larger indirect transmission route but
but if we really want to use this
information to say this looks like it
was a direct transmission
uh we could we could maybe get confused
by other genomes that look
just just as similar without looking at
the intra-host single-engine variants
thank you and regarding the snps can
snps
cause the non-detection of positive
samples by rt
pcr yeah this
really varies this great question by
platform um some platforms are more
uh sensitive to uh to smvs or snips that
that could occur in the genome
and some are more robust but some plum
platforms if you have
one or two or a handful this could
really interfere with the detection
or even just one and other platforms are
more robust to this base and again these
aren't things i had
time to really fully fully address but
based on
the specific strategy in the platform
for the
rtpcr-based detection it could be that a
handful of snip changes
does interfere with a positive detection
call so it's something we really want to
think about
and is thought about when when these are
being designed but something i didn't
get a chance to mention
is even if we design this with our best
algorithms methods out there and there's
a lot of great methods i don't i won't
be able to list them all out
um sometimes we just don't have all of
the up-to-date information again
so this this really started ramping up
let's say back in march
let's say we did our design of these uh
primer probes for detection back in
march well now three months have passed
and it could be that now uh
part as part of the you know we we see
additional viral genomes that have snips
in the position where we
physicians where we previously thought
were highly conserved or identical
across so
it's it's not that it's it's it's just
the kind of the the hard part of this
whole problem as
uh merging situation as additional data
arrives
um both snip and isnv data is really
crucial for understanding what's going
on
and so as additional data arrives and i
this is another
figure i wasn't able to show uh but uh
let's say we go back to march
we have a handful maybe maybe tens of
tens of genomes right
and then and then we get into hundreds
and then we get to thousands and now i
you know i mentioned in one slide we
have
over 30 000 genomes and this is growing
so rapidly that all of this is
additional information for us to look at
and say
how do we design uh effective tests uh
that are robust to changes
and we have more information how we can
do that and we're getting a better sense
of the mutational landscape
so uh yes it can uh really varies by
platform
so i'm not gonna get in you know some
will work better than others
but but it really gets into how how
these are designed
but it's something certainly to think
about and it's something as
more data emerges it may update our
understanding of what these conserved
regions are
so as as there are more changes
introduced so over
and dr time what is the difference
between
is nv and snp
yeah yeah so i uh this is something that
for those that are
haven't thought really carefully about
this for a long time and even
sometimes it's confusing for me when i'm
describing this but it's um
essentially again when you're thinking
about
uh for a given person when you sequence
um
a given person a swab let's say we have
a nasal swab and we put it on a
sequencer
we have a collection of uh breeds
and then we're we're gonna we're gonna
create a consensus
uh genome assembly uh and then and then
we're gonna align all those reads back
to it
and so any isnv in that scenario is
going to be any anything that occurs at
less than 50
so let's say for a given position uh we
align
or or map or 10 10 reads to that
position
and if we see a t that occurs in three
of those 10 that would be an isnv
meaning that it doesn't reach this
consensus level but it's present in the
population
and and we we don't think it's an error
we think it's it occurs too frequently
to be an error
but it occurs not frequently enough to
be a consensus level
uh a kind of smv or a snip okay
and then snips are when we think about
just think about when we're just dealing
with genome genomic data from just aid
so we have
these 33 000 genomes when we're
comparing the genomic information
forget about the the read information
from the dna so we already have the
genome assemblies and we're comparing
all the genomic information
the genomes the assembled genomes which
are uh assembled through the consensus
of all of these
uh all the data i mentioned uh those
would be
would be snips so we're thinking about
um
consensus level or greater uh
differences so
uh and and we can think of these as
inter-host also another way of thinking
of this is intra-host
versus inter-host differences it's
another kind of maybe a little bit more
cleaner way of thinking about this is
looking at changes in starscopy to
within a given person that you might not
observe in other
individuals or patients and then snips
are more inter-hosts things that you
observe
across patients so and they can
intersect which i described in the
presentation
but that's kind of the main difference
uh again when we think about
uh we get uh you know we get we we get
uh
we're cub id positive uh we have we have
we have the virus and it replicates
creates many copies and then there's
this population of virions
and each each one of those might contain
its own a
slightly different version and
differences
but then then so that's one that's one
way to look at into this problem
and then another way is actually go for
all of the assembled
the consensus sequences or the genomes
that have been assembled from each of
these patients and compare them to each
other
and then we see kind of uh inter-person
or cross-toast differences that might be
of interest so
i think one of the main points of the
presentation is really understanding
that there's
kind of two sides of this to think about
and consider uh for these viruses and we
really want to kind of combine that
information look at the consensus level
information also the yeah so the
inter-host with the intra-host so
i think i think i think that's kind of
the the one of the main points of this
uh
the presentation but uh but yeah that's
a great question
thank you we have time for a couple more
questions and again thank you to our
audience any questions not answered
today will be answered via email
well the variations in the gene sequence
of the spike protein
could it hamper the vaccine development
yeah i mean i you know i'm a computer
scientist and i don't i don't want to
get too
into any uh i at this stage it's really
i'm thinking about this as an
exploratory that's why i use the words
landscape and looking at this
certainly um you know when we project
this out and think about it more
carefully which i'm not ready to really
kind of get into this
uh because i want to look at more and i
want to look at you know a lot of the
other
scientific results and think about this
more but certainly there are certain
mutational patterns
that that may cause more than
you know be challenging in different
ways than what i just described the two
the two methods
the two kind of primary kind of or you
know what the impact on
uh what's impact on kind of molecular
diagnostics and what's the
what's the impact on maybe utility on
for for transmission
so so certainly that's one of the main
goals of where uh
we're at currently the team that i
acknowledged and and
and even covert uh broadly uh is looking
into all of these changes and then
trying to overlay this with
with other potential kind of negative
impacts or
consequences and thinking about
certainly thinking about
vaccines a vaccine but again there's no
i haven't you know there's nothing
really
kind of for for me to add there other
than
it's it's it's an interesting question
but but more broadly
thinking about all of this in the
context of
of the virus and of the host and also
the part
um that i didn't talk about today but
there's there's there's also
a microbiome component so so just just
putting that all together and
and again that's just wanted to stress
why uh i think it's such a critical
thing to have a team
of diverse expertise so when when i'm
looking into these uh patterns
intra-host and inter-host diversity i
could
i could then connect up with an expert
in in the area of vaccine development
and say how would would these changes
impact uh anything or would this help in
the design
you know so so i haven't you know those
are that's a great question but i think
you know
more follow-up research is needed to
really precisely answer that and then
look into it more carefully
thank you so much our final question
what sequencing
platform was used to obtain the
consensus
and the and read sequences yep that's
great question
um i kind of skipped over that a little
bit uh so
for the um new york city houston samples
that was an illumina novaseq
okay um short read uh sequences
uh low error uh shorter sequences i
think 150
base pairs in length and then and then
some of the just eight samples
it's a mix i don't i don't have the
statistics memorized but it's
uh there's a lot of uh oxford nanopore
data and there's a lot of illumina
sequencing
data there i think those are the two
dominant uh ones and then and then
inside of that there are some variants
and variation but overall
it's uh to answer your question uh for
the analysis that
i presented today we primarily had
to say genomes that were kind of
constructed from illumina sequencing
platforms and oxford nanopore and then
for all the intra-host diversity
or most of the inter-host diversity
analysis i present today was
uh illumina novaseq 6000. so that's
that's what
that's what was used
thank you so much for your presentation
today dr triage
would you like to provide any closing
remarks for our audience
before we leave yeah no no
just thanks again to lab roots for um
for inviting me to give this uh
presentation and and thank you susie for
for
for hosting and moderating i really
appreciate it and uh yeah
feel free because i'm happy to field any
follow-up questions
and uh would really encourage everyone
to go check out uh
the covert website www.cov.irt.org
if you're interested in getting involved
and it's been a
pleasure to present today on this
platform
and thank you again sir for your time
today and for your important research
and before we go i want to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted on
the on-demand period will be addressed
by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
through the end of the year
2020. labyrinths will alert you via
email when it's available for replay
and we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time thank you be safe take
care bye